(very quiet music)
Ann Temkin: I'm standing
in front of a platform
full of sculptures by Constantin Brancusi,
a Romanian-born artist who walked from
Romania to Paris when
he was a young artist.
He made sculptures that explored
the idea of abstraction.
In the center is Mademoiselle Pogany.
The bronze is dated 1913 and it's based
on a marble and made
from a plaster from 1912.
It was actually a portrait
of a friend of his,
Margit Pogany, a young Hungarian woman.
When the plaster was on
view in 1913 in New York,
it became one of the star
pieces of the Armory Show,
not in the sense of being most beloved,
but being most ridiculed by
the press and by the visitors.
Together with Marcel Duchamp's
Nude Descending a Staircase,
Mademoiselle Pogany was lampooned
probably more than any other object there.
What was the problem?
It had a name.
Brancusi was clearly telling the visitors
that this was a portrait.
This was not a head, it was
an egg, is what they said.
Brancusi delineated the hair
not by any sculpted forms of curls.
She was considered bald.
The facial features by the slightest
of descriptive lines or incisions
were seen as nonsensical.
We're at a point in history where
Brancusi is beginning to abstract from
a fairly naturalistic image into forms
that were much more pure and simplified
down to their really essential features.
This was something that today, I think,
100 years later, we all look at and know
that we're looking at a woman.
At that time, it was almost
incomprehensible that
that would be how you could
represent somebody's face.
(very quiet music)